the Bible says when I was a child I
spoke as a child I understood as a child
I thought as a child and when I became a
man I put away childish things when we
moved through adulthood we look back
fondly on those simpler times the
creativity we exhibited our fearlessness
how we approached new things with wonder
the film's nominated for Best Animated
Feature possessed the ability to move us
all no need to put things away but
instead embrace and enjoyed a shared
experience here are the nominees for
Best Animated Feature Film Incredibles
- Brad Bird John Walker and Nicole
parody window I love dogs
Wes Anderson Scott Rudin Stephen medals
Jeremy Dawson Mira Mamoru Hosoda
and Yuichiro psycho Ralph breaks the
internet rich more Phil Johnston and
Claude Spencer
spider-man into the spider-verse black
Pacifica feed oMG what we rotten Phil
Lord and Christopher Miller and the
Oscar goes to your right
[Music]
[Applause]
and Christopher Miller this is the first
Oscar and nomination for Bob for
Sacchetti Peter Ramsey
Rodney Rothman Fillmore and Christopher
Miller there's a lot of us Wow
hey um Thank You Academy
Thank You Sony we share this with our
fellow producers cast a crew there's 800
filmmakers who push boundaries and took
risks to make people feel powerful and
seen so when we hear that somebody
somebody's kid was watching the movie
and turned to them and said he looks
like me or they speak Spanish like us we
feel like we already want to our
audience thank you so much we love you
and we just want we want you all to know
we see you you're powerful this world
needs you
okay this world needs you so please
we're all counting on you thank you on
behalf of everyone that made this movie
we want to thank our families who stayed
with us for four years on this this is
for you we love you all